bitcoin denominated assets i saw this uh
tweet from our boy muneeb ali
on twitter and it got me thinking i
wrote about it this morning if you look
at
bitcoin denominated assets what we have
learned is that every asset in the
financial system is normally denominated
in dollars and so if you think about the
dollar
over some sort of other asset you are
basically trying to measure the
appreciation or depreciation of that
asset against the dollar the problem
with doing that is that the dollar is
not a stable value there's over 38 of
all dollars in circulation that have
been entered in the last 18 months so
the dollar has been rapidly depreciating
and so of course asset prices are going
to go up the dollar depreciates the
asset gets stronger against that dollar
so it's very hard to normalize over
years and years and years or decades
what is the price of these assets and so
this is a great example where muni was
able to say okay well what is the s p
500 denominated in bitcoin
well guess what
the s p 500 has been crashing against
bitcoin for the last decade it is just
down and to the right literally bitcoin
is eating the s p 500. when you
denominate every single financial asset
in bitcoin rather than in dollars
they're all crashing the financial
wherewithal of these portfolios was
denominated in bitcoin versus dollars is
atrocious
every asset is down now what happens is
when we denominate in dollars it looks
like all the asset prices are going up
real estate is going up stocks are going
up commodities are going up other
currencies are going up etc that is
because the dollar is being devalued at
an incredible pace when you denominate
it in something like digital sound money
bitcoin they are all down significantly
and so what that reminds us is that when
you look at the price of a financial
asset you have to ask yourself not only
what is the asset that i'm looking at
but what is the currency in which it is
being denominated because if that
currency is being devalued at a historic
pace like we are seeing with the us
dollar right now what you get is an
inflated asset price that isn't
necessarily an indicator that true value
has accrued to that asset you simply are
seeing the underlying currency being
devalued and that is what is driving the
price up again if you denominate your
portfolio in bitcoin and you look at all
of the financial assets that you own
smp dao nasdaq commodities
bonds real estate whatever
if you go and you look at those assets
denominated in bitcoin what you are
likely to see is that those assets are
actually down in bitcoin terms but
they're up in dollar terms and so it
starts to beg the question
how good of an investment are these
assets actually if most of the value
accrual has not been from true value
being created but instead because the
currency in which they are denominated
has been devalued at an incredible rate
what do you guys think about the fact
that literally just like the s p 500 has
just fallen off a cliff
yeah i think uh senator nose dive we
talked about it the other day and i'm
curious like when i asked you where you
thought bitcoin was going to be right
like whether it's 10 20 50 years from
now and your answer was mostly revolving
around like we're gonna stop pricing
things in u.s dollars or whatever
currency it is and you're gonna look at
things in bitcoin and how much it cost
uh in terms of bitcoin so like how long
does that take though right and does
that does that filter down everything is
it just hey i'm gonna buy this coffee at
at the store or the shop or is it home
prices is it the s p is it stocks in
general is it real estate does it filter
down to everything and how long does
that take
you're saying how long will it take for
the dollar to be the
currency in which people denominate
things bitcoin or yeah i'm sorry bitcoin
uh it depends on the geography first
right so i think that there's two places
where it's going to happen one is on the
internet for sure right if you think of
bitcoin rising to be the global reserve
currency of the internet i think that
that is uh already underway there are
some places that will say hey you can
buy our uh good or service in dollars or
in bitcoin and they'll price it in
bitcoin terms so i think that'll start
to happen in kind of a digitally native
environment the second place i think is
not in the developed world but the
developing world in places like el
salvador nigeria etc where people
basically say listen this is a currency
that i save in it is the global store of
wealth that i use and so if i'm going to
use this as the purchasing power
protection then it makes sense for me
simply to just denominate the goods or
services in bitcoin as well but i think
it goes kind of digital
global then it goes developing world
then eventually it'll permeate into the
developed world the key part of this is
i don't think that it has to be a
hundred percent adoption of bitcoin
right you can look today like there is a
very big difference between a digitally
native business and an analog business
so let's look at a different type of
technology how many restaurants have
mobile apps
really probably not as many as you would
think right from a penetration
standpoint how many of them use online
ordering more and more today than ever
before right how many of them are
digitally native where they're all over
social they have apps they have online
ordering etc those are the new versions
it's going to be the same exact thing
with economies right some economies are
going to be super digitally native guess
what the internet the global economy is
going to be the most digitally native
right that it's born there it was bred
there it will stay there
but then the developed worlds are
actually likely to leapfrog the uh the
i'm sorry developing worlds will
leapfrog the developed worlds right look
at mobile banking if you think of a
number of different african countries
they have better mobile banking
infrastructure than we have here in the
united states why it's because every
single person that started out uh in the
banking system their first entry point
was with mobile banking they didn't have
a legacy bank system and then like oh by
the way we have this new app you should
download it and then it'll allow you
services from the legacy system no it
was all built from scratch mobile first
because that was the only technology
that they had available to them and so
you would literally onboard create an
account fund the account spend out of it
etc all on mobile that mobile system is
way better than here in the united
states we also see in places like asia
if you go to asia and you look at the
kind of financial infrastructure there
it's light years ahead of the united
states right they're using qr codes
they're checking out the whole idea of
being able to tap not swipe or insert
but tap that's been uh pervasive there
for a very very long time we're just now
getting that u.s over the last two or
three years we didn't even have qr codes
at restaurants before the pandemics
right like to scan for menus and stuff
and that's been prevailing in other
countries forever yeah so i think that
just naturally you're gonna get the
digitally native uh uh kind of economies
are gonna adopt this stuff first what i
will say is i have been shocked that
more people have not opened their eyes
to the idea of denominating financial
assets in bitcoin it's really coming out
of like the most hardcore of the bitcoin
community that's where you're starting
to see this happen um and what i think
is going to start to enter the
conversation is if i am a digitally
native young person for the most part
and i denominate my life in bitcoin or
any other digital currency right for
bitcoin is the example i use that's
where i said my time but it could be any
of these things
why would i then go price assets in
dollars those assets being the stock
market or bonds or real estate or
commodities or any of this stuff
it doesn't make sense my my personal
reserve asset is bitcoin so why would i
then go use somebody else it would be
like us in the legacy world saying hey i
get paid in dollars i save in dollars i
invest in dollars and i pay my
government taxes in dollars but when i
look at the financial markets i'm going
to denominate everything in pesos yeah
you'd be like wait what like i gotta do
the conversion like it's just confusing
so instead what's gonna happen is we're
gonna start getting what i'll call like
investor-led or demand-led
pricing of assets in non-fiat currencies
because people are gonna say my personal
reserve currency is not a fiat currency
and therefore i want to price these
assets so i can measure over time
what is the movement of this asset if
you look at that s p 500 chart
who would invest in that if i didn't
tell you what the asset was and i said
hey by the way here's the performance
over the last decade do you want to buy
this asset the only way you buy this
chart is because you think something has
changed and you're it's now bottomed and
it's going to reverse and go the other
way well i think it scares a lot of
people too because of this because this
is how the chart looks right so if you
look at bitcoin it's appreciated so much
over the last you know decade or so that
it scares people when you start pricing
things in bitcoin because the the the uh
the divergence is so great but when you
think about people can now some people
are getting paid in bitcoin right there
you can pay your mortgage in bitcoin you
can save in bitcoin you can do all these
things right so when you start seeing it
as uh kind of that currency of the
future that you were talking about with
the us dollar of you getting paid in it
saving it paying the government doing
all these things you can quickly see why
some people would adopt it and to be
fair like there's probably thousands and
thousands of people who are doing this
currently right like you said you do it
personally and you've been doing it for
the last few years of just in your head
or whatever it is denominating
everything in bitcoin before you make a
purchase before you save before you do
something so there's always there's
already thousands of people doing this
it's just a matter of rolling it out to
a bigger scale as bitcoin gets adopted i
think that's right john what do you
think it's going to be a transition
right it's not going to be an overnight
thing um you see this already even the
united states dating back to the last 20
years i've seen right you see a usd
pricing right under it you'll see um a
price in canadian dollars you see a lot
of different things and it's going to go
digital i agree with that it's going to
go to developing countries first because
they're most likely to adopt the
innovation and to be honest u.s is
normally a little slow for change in
that aspect of it um and then i think
we'll see it here in the united states
uh whether that is bitcoin or any other
digital currency we're going to see it
whether they create a central bank coin
or whatever right um you're going to see
it but it's going to take a while to
happen this is why i've been saying
bitcoin is the apex predator of
financial markets it's because no matter
what the financial asset is if you
denominate it in bitcoin it's down over
the last five or ten years and the
reason why it's down is because we have
watched the best performing asset
absolutely eat markets it's an apex
predator it eats everything in its path
every single financial asset that you
put in front of bitcoin it absolutely
destroys it and the reason is because we
are watching a fixed supply asset be
priced by the world and what is
happening is that the macro environment
is so egregious it's so chaotic it's so
uncertain it's so manipulated that
people are saying to themselves where
can i go where i have certainty and i
have predictability and they're finding
it in bitcoin and so you've seen a
absolute massive amount of capital flow
into the market and that market now has
priced this asset at around a trillion
dollars almost a trillion dollars today
for bitcoin and so when you go from zero
to a trillion over a 12 13 year period
and then you use that as your base
currency and denominate other assets in
bitcoin it destroys everything that is
why bitcoin is the apex predator of
markets is because every single asset
has to bend the knee at the feet of the
king
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]